ラララララ♪ロラ♪ローラ♪
ローラローラローラ♪ローラロローラ♪
ローラ♪スプラローラ♪スプラローラとローラ♪
やべ……出オチした……(焦)
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ﾌﾟﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙrrrrrrrrrrrrﾗｯﾎｫｰｰｰ!!!!!!
俺は！この時を待っていた！ﾊｧｯ！
ﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃﾝﾃｹﾃﾝ
HAJIME☆DRUM☆TIME
KU☆RA☆ZU☆SHI
ついにくら寿司が我々の業界に名乗りを上げた
なんとですね！
なんとですよ！
無添くら寿司から…………
GACHI☆DURM☆TIME
ｶﾞﾋﾞｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰﾝ(効果音)
牛丼が発表されました
すばらしいでございます88888
ただね、その出し方よ
出し方というかキャッチーがすごかった
370円で売ってたんですけども
今回このくら寿司で販売された牛丼の名前が
とりあえず僕牛丼大好きなんですよ！
きっと視聴者の皆さまの中に牛丼屋さんで僕にあった人結構いると思います
覚えてるか？
そんな話はどうでもいいｨｨｨｨｨ
牛丼ほんとにすきなんで
はたして牛丼を超えた牛丼というものがいかほどなものかというのをちょっと
確かめていかないといけないと僕は思ったわけなので今回このくら寿司の牛丼をお持ち帰りで買って今こっちに持ち帰ってここに帰ってきたわけでこざいます
今日の夜ごはん！
今回この無添くら寿司でかった
牛丼を超えた牛丼たるものを口の中へ運んでそのレビューをしたいと思っております
では行こうｯｯ！！
ﾎﾟﾝ!(効果音)
ハイッ！
ほぉ……いたってシンプル
なかｍ…中身も割とちゃんとした牛丼ですね
牛肉と、ふつあケース外そう
なんでケース外すまで説明してんだ
なかなかしっかりとした牛丼ですね
たまねぎもちゃんと味がきいてるみたいでございます
においだいじだお（やる夫風）
おぉなるほど
個人的には結構吉野家よりですな
吉野家寄りのにおいがします
果たしてその味の方はいかほどなものか！
いざ、
あ～なるほど
美味しそうだなパッと見
じゃあ・・・いただきます。
ﾄﾞｫ↑ﾝ↓
ﾃ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃ↑ﾃﾞ↑ｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪﾝ↓
心の声:なっ……なんでこの味は！？
心の声:今までに存在していた牛丼の店舗には感じることのできなかった
心の声:YUTAKANAHUUMI!
心の声:牛肉の煮込み時間が違うからであろうか
心の声:これは七時間ほど煮込んであるとみた（カンペ）
心の声:寿司屋さんというだけあってまさかこの牛肉
心の声:魚介だしで煮込んでいるというのか
心の声:やわらかい舌ざわりの牛肉
心の声:甘味があふれんばかりに口の中を豊かにしてくれる
心の声:TAMANEGI!
心の声:この牛丼……
心の声:まさに……
心の声:この牛丼……まさに……！
心の声:絶☆品
め↑っちゃくっちゃ美味しいぃぃぃ
けど超えてはいないぞ
超えてはいません
牛丼は超えてはいないうん
間違いない超えてはいない
うんでもうまいです
お米もまさか酢飯使ってんじゃねえかなと思ったけど
酢飯も使ってなく
しいていうなら結構やっぱりね吉野家寄りですミルキーな味がします
甘味が利いてますね甘くて食べやすいから
多分子供たちも普通に好きですねこのタイプは
うん……うぅん！
美味かった！ごちそうさまでした
はいと言う訳で食べてみたんですけども
美味いっすよ！美味しい！
ひじょ～～～～に美味しかったが
すごい味はよくできていたと思います
普通に牛丼屋さんの牛丼に引けを取らない美味しさでした
めっちゃまじめにレポートしてるな
ぃや美味しかったよ！！
まあちょっとこの牛丼マイスターとしては
やっぱ結局吉野家が好きなんですよ実は
と言う訳で皆さんもぜひよかったら
牛丼を超えた牛丼食べてみてください
どや顔のお手本
じゃあな！
もう一個たーべよ！
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
ただいまから2016年11/05のニュースをお送りします
ももち引退　メンバーは驚かず
韓国 朴大統領退陣求め数万人がデモ
さんまが31年ぶりにNHKに本格出演
男児不明 遺体5カ月間自宅に?
ポケGO規制要請の市長を脅迫動画
これにてニュースを終わります